today i'm very excited to cancel
a momentously deserving individual named
brittany
james md and brittany james md is
certainly the kind of md who wants you
to always acknowledge the md
when addressing her she describes
herself in her bio as an anti-racist
feminist a physician and activist and a
scholar
it probably tells you all you need to
know that she lists anti-racist
feminists before physician
she also lists her pronouns as expected
but bernie james md
tweeted this a couple days ago she said
my doing my own business shopping and a
middle-aged white woman asked me if i
worked there
when i looked at her blankly and
answered back in a deadpan voice no
she giggled it off and said i was just
wondering where to put this shirt back
but i'm a bad person if i go off
well no you're not a bad person if you
go off you're a bad person in general
um and also you're a bad person if you
go off but she continues
kicking myself for not saying i'm a
physician and letting her die of
embarrassment
but something tells me she wouldn't even
have the decency to be embarrassed
most of these types don't stop asking
black people why they are angry
i can't even shop in peace the worst
part about everyday racism of white
folks is that we aren't even allowed to
be angry about it
as a black woman it would have co it
would have come back on me i'm tired
now after reading this i very much want
to see dr james at a retail store so
that i can ask her if she works there
and then when she says i'm a physician
i'll say sure you are sweetheart now now
tell me what where do while do i get the
laundry detergent
and i would like to say that to her just
to annoy her because
annoying entitled jerks is a virtuous
act in my opinion
and i do believe in uh in knowing
entitled jerks equally and inequitably
by the way
i don't care about your race or your sex
my disdain
for entitled jerks knows no demographic
boundaries
in fact in this case we should stipulate
that we're dealing with an entitled
elitist jerk
because what she's really saying here is
that retail workers are beneath her
she quite clearly feels that she belongs
to a social strata
far above that of a lowly customer
service worker and a name tag
something tells me that if someone heard
her and saw her and assumed that she was
a rocket scientist
or an architect or something she
wouldn't be nearly as traumatized
so this is more than anything about her
own fragile ego and the social caste
system
that she has concocted in her head and
of course placed herself
at the top of now me
i'm not offended when people confuse me
with an employee at a store
i i don't consider myself to be superior
in any way
to the guy stocking shelves at walmart
so if somebody thinks i'm that guy fine
what do i care
and yes i have been asked the do you
work here question many times in my life
admittedly not as much recently and i
think that's partly because
when i'm at a store these days most of
the time
i'm shopping off of a list that my wife
gave me and the list is about the length
of like the dead sea scrolls and i'm
walking around the aisles
looking somewhat frantic and bewildered
and obsessively going back to my phone
as a reference point
um the point is i just don't have the
vibe of a guy who works in the facility
every day
and knows where everything is but back
in my younger days of shopping just for
myself
uh and and knowing exactly what i wanted
and where it was
because everything i wanted was in the
frozen food section i got confused with
workers
much more often that's that's because
when someone makes this mistake
they're responding if anything if
they're responding to anything they're
responding to your demeanor
and often the clothes that you're
wearing and maybe some other signifiers
that have nothing to do with race
i probably wouldn't ever be mistaken for
an employee at
hot topic or victoria's secret because
in those places i would stick out like
well like a bearded guy in his mid-30s
at hot topic or victoria's secret
it's not racial though not everything is
racial in fact most of the things that
people think are racial
these days actually aren't so what we
have here is yet another example of a
person with a racial framework
a person who sees everything through a
racial lens and who assumes that
everybody else does the same in her mind
anything that could theoretically be
racism must be racism
it's not just the first explanation she
jumps to but it's the only explanation
she has categorically ruled out all
other potential causes
and she's done this again in spite of
the fact that the interaction she
describes hasn't has happened to
everyone
it's totally normal and it's not a big
deal by the way if you want to test this
out then just imagine
a white man in a red shirt at target
have you ever gone to target in a red
shirt
or a blue shirt at best buy standing
next to a black man
in a white shirt or a gray shirt or
something who do you think's gonna get
stopped by
someone who assumes that they're an
employee or we could do it this way a
white guy
in a collared shirt with a tie in khakis
and a black guy in pajama pants
who gets the angry older woman coming
over to him and saying excuse me
are you the manager clearly not the guy
in pajamas no matter his race
in fact you could argue that getting
confused for an employee
is a compliment because maybe you were
the only person in the store
who wasn't dressed like a slob who just
woke up with a hangover 12 minutes ago
but there's another part of this aside
from the racial obsessions of brittany
here
the real driver is not even that but but
more so just garden variety narcissism
narcissism she is someone who assumes
and there are a lot of people like this
out there that every banal
annoyance she encounters must be unique
must be targeted
must be sinister must be all about her
somehow
she doesn't want to think that this is
this is the sort of thing that happens
to everybody
partly because it would destroy her
racial narrative but even more because
it would destroy
the narrative that she keeps closer to
the heart the narrative that she is the
center of the world
and everything that happens to her
really matters
everything is a big deal if she were to
admit that this is an everyday
completely normal utterly unremarkable
event
then she's not only deprived of an
opportunity to feel wounded but also she
must admit
that her life isn't quite as unique as
she assumed and hoped
here's one thing i'll guarantee i
guarantee that britney
is the kind of person who honks
while stuck in traffic on the highway
everybody's sitting in the same traffic
jam
everyone is suffering the same
inconvenience nobody likes it
but there's always that person honking
as if she is the main
character of the traffic jam and all the
other cars are conspiring to prevent her
from getting to her pilates class on
time
everybody else is in her way she's not
in their way
they're in her way i mean why is there
traffic on the road in the first place
well because lots of people are trying
to go in the same direction at the same
time that's also why nobody has the
right to be angry about it
everybody is part of the problem but
brittany can't see it that way
bernie's also the sort of person who
comes home at night and inflicts her
self-centered miseries on whoever has
the misfortune of living with
her she'll go into long drawn-out epic
stories
describing every irritation she
experienced that day
explaining how everyone is out to get
her all the time the world is so unfair
and so on
what she really needs but probably
doesn't have
is some kind-hearted compassionate
person to say to her
hey brittany shut up you're not special
you're not a victim the only thing
unique about you
is that you handle inconvenience much
worse than average
than the average person other than that
your life is exceedingly average
your experiences are not incredible or
even interesting
and so i'm going to leave now and i'll
let you continue ranting to the wall
because i suspect
it'd be all the same to you anyway
brittany needs to hear that lots of
people do
but like lots of people she never has
until now
so you're welcome and also of course
you're cancelled listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated